welcome to science breakthroughs from
science mission I am sadashiva pi I am
going to discuss a couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of May twelfth let's start first we
are going to discuss a paper published
by marina from dr. suchen Zhang's lab in
cell reports the paper takes a leap in
the regenerative therapies by
demonstrating successful use of
autologous IPSC cells in monkeys why
this paper is so important teratoma
formation and rejection of autologous
IPS esas has been reported in mice so
there is no clear therapeutic advantage
for the use of autologous stem cells
this paper provides data from monkeys
that give some hope for the future
autologous therapies let's look at the
data authors derived IPS is from skin
tissue of three rhesus monkeys aged 8 to
10 years using yamanaka factors and
differentiated them into neuronal cells
schematic of differentiation protocol is
shown here similar to human PSEs reese's
IPS is differentiated to neuro epithelia
that organized into neural tube like
russets and expressed neural ectoderm
transcription factors pax6 by day 42 of
differentiation using hedgehog and
fibroblast growth factor eight
thirty-seven percent of the cells were
beta 3 2 billion positive neurons
sixteen percent were as hundred be
immature pesticides and the remainings
were largely nesting positive
progenitors no oligodendrocytes were
observed at this stage which usually
appear at a much later stage during
primate stem cell differentiation
the major neuronal populations were
positive for gaba 49-percent and
tyrosine hydroxylase 16-percent GSP is
reporter introduced into the cells for
detection so these cells are used for
transplantation or grafting authors
created a monkey model of parkinson's
disease by unilateral intra karate'd
artery infusion of the neurotoxin mptp
all the three monkeys develop a stable
Hemi parkinsonian conditioned cells
differentiated at day 42 contained
immature neurons that were largely
positive for gfp as shown in the
previous slide were transplanted into
the stratum and substantia [ __ ] of the
same monkeys 12 to 18 months post mptp
lesion without any immune suppression
authors examined the graph six months
post-transplantation using stereological
and immunocytochemical analysis on
serial coronal sections analysis of
gfp-positive cells indicated that about
sixty-three percent were mapped to
positive neurons twenty-two percent were
gfap positive neurons and approximately
ten percent were myelin basic protein
oligodendrocytes the vast majority of
gfp-positive neurons were gaba positive
and few were positive for tyrosine
hydroxylase this may explain why the
authors did not observe obvious
behavioral recovery data is not shown
here you know staining for ki67 labeling
mitotic cells showed no positive cells
in the graphs again data not shown here
indicating differentiation of grafted
new progenitors no cells in the grafted
brain were positive for pluripotent stem
cells and for
non-neuronal lineage markers you may
know staining for cd3 + cd8 for
lymphocytes on monkey brain sections
showed no obvious difference between the
graph and surrounding host tissues so no
immune reaction splain tissues used as
positive controls were immunoreactive
for all the markers immunostaining for
human leukocyte antigen d related for
microglia and macrophages revealed
microglial cells throughout the brain
you know staining for several gfap
showed a moderate increase in intensity
these results indicate IPS could be used
for therapeutic purposes the scarcity of
dopamine neurons in the graphs and lack
of functional improvement in the animals
are likely due to the neural
differentiation strategy that did not
yield sufficient number of mid brain
neurons better differentiation protocol
might yield better results let's hope
for the best next we will see a paper
published in science translational
medicine use of antidepressant to reduce
CSF a beta production in healthy
subjects why this paper is so important
ultimus disease has affected millions of
people around the world and still no
cure is available any reprieved to the
patient's save millions of dollars in
health care costs and better life for
patients this paper provides encouraging
data from human subjects using serotonin
reuptake inhibitor citalopram let's look
at the data this experiment was done in
12 month old a PP ps1 mice animals were
treated with various amounts of
citalopram and
CSF a beta was measured using
microdialysis probe inserted into the
hippocampus as shown in the figure
setelah prompt significantly reduces a
beta levels in the CSF after 21 to 24
hours after the gay administration
six-month-old a PP ps1 mice were treated
with the sitter low prom 10 milligram
per kg per day or vehicle
intraperitoneal for 28 days and imaged
using two-photon microscopy nope new
plaques formed in drug treated mice
while new plaque formation seen in the
vehicle treated mice so more number of
plaques in the vehicle treated animals
then the drug treated ones settle up mom
also attenuated the growth in size of
pre-existing plugs citalopram also
reduce the appearance of new plugs but
did not make disappear the plugs already
present let's look at what happens in
the humans human volunteers who received
citalopram had lower mean CSF
concentrations of a beta compared to
placebo the mean production rate of a
beta over hours thirteen to twenty two
was significantly slower in citalopram
treated individuals but the clearance
rate of a beta was unchanged these
results suggest that citalopram might be
useful in treating other MERS patient
thereby reducing the for formation of
new plugs and reducing the increase in
the size of already developed plox so it
is not a cure but might provide relief
to patients and if given early on might
help the patient to
read a better quality life that's all
for now thank you for watching science
breakthrough from science mission